Hawks Debbie found huge mistake huge
mistake
just a young inexperienced team not
knowing they needed to file to stop the
clock and the heat through the right
thing they keep making the quick extra
pass and then the Hawks can never lock
anybody up for a foul for the first time
this season the heat beat the Hawks and
for the first time this season the heat
win a third straight game at home the
Heat win it 114 to 113 and Miami goes to
29 and 34 they have the same record as
the team they play Wednesday night the
Charlotte Hornets so a big win the night
sets up mr. herder what did he caught
your attention I so yeah yeah early in
the year a good friend of mine told me
about him when he was younger
daddy used to wear my they wear my shoes
he were number three because of me he
looked up to me so I knew I was gonna
surprise him at that the last time we
played him but I really liked his game
he's somewhere since preseason when we
played them all the way it said now he's
got to so much better so for one number
three to another I thought I was Swiss
jerseys with him Serge the exchanges
have great stories every single time